分
[音楽]
んはぁっ
おやこの bgm こんにちははじめ社長です皆さんスマートフォン
何使ってますか今回はですねソフトバンクさんが発売されているこちら
エクスペディア xz 1を紹介しようと思います
これすごいんですよ何がすごいかといいますととりあえずカメラがめちゃくちゃ綺麗
です後音がめちゃくちゃん良い
そしてリップ
でがん
とてもキーというもうとてもハイスペックなスマートフォンになっているんですけども
いろんな機能があるんですけれどもその中でも今回は3 d クリエイターという機能
を使ってみようと思います3 d クリエイターとは人の顔やものを3 d で撮影
することができる機能のことです風さんもこのエクスペディアの3 d クリエイター
の軌道を使ってお父さん
3 d
だしてたんですけども今日は実際にこの xperia の3 d 機能使って僕を
くりフィギュアにしてみようと思います自体も変わったね
昔だかその3 d フィーに行って見つかりそうなイメージだったんですけど嫌だと
もうスマホでてきちゃうという時代になってきました
次で早速3 d クリエイターの機能を使って3 d フィギュアの撮影をしていこう
と思うんですけどもなんかすごい簡単みたいなのでもうちょっとやっていきたいと
おもいます
ない子おっ
ん
パインというわけで無事3 b 度撮影が終了しました
を種類ぐらいいろんな顔のレパートリーとったんでちょっと見ていきました
はいじゃあさっそくどんなのかとれたが見ていきましょう例えばこれでとかパッと見
普通の絵なんですけどもこれが実はもう3 d になってますほら
[音楽]
すごいっすよねーああ
バッハ
これ僕は自分の顔で撮ったんですけどものとかも
3 d で撮影することがあったのでございます
すごいなて臼田までしたもちゃんと出てる
あーという感じで結構なクオリティの3 d 画像が取ることが可能です敗では3 d
撮影した写真3を早速3 d フィギュアとして注文していきましょう
この子3 d フィギュアにしていきましょう3 d プリントをしって
れるフィギュアを出力するで踊るアップロードしますはいそれではプロの2です
よしきたするよ選択を肩までの部分しかないんですけどもあなたの部分をどれにするか
というのは君れるみたいです
色々ありますねちょっとレイズフォーマルドレスとフィギュアにスパでこんなカルーん
だろせましょうかはい
はいというわけで無事の公民のフィギュアの注文も無事終了したのでしばらく
3 d フィギュア完成するまでお待ちは大
4つ
これがでは上げていきましょう奪って強い強いこれ
一人でこれが生え発達
ゲイな頭の形がすごいそっくりなんですよね
でまってまってナンです絵巻この感じだという作るのか
もうすぐ小さいなはいうん
par
よくできてますよよくできてるんですけど売るのかもがおかしいんだと思いましたよ
3つ目はい
バッハ
[音楽]
芸南凹凸が好きリアルなんだよな4つめいきます
4つも小さいなはいおおっ
次でも似てるは完全に俺だぁ探す一つこれから最終的に ok だと思いますせーの
はい
はいというわけで xperia を使ってこのやって3 d フィギュアを作ること
もできます
[音楽]
十条においてみますえっ
ああああああ
ちょっと入れないんだよ
ええええええ
4 f
[音楽]
ん
えっ
[音楽]
10秒企画にして
えっそうですし
公園
1小さいん
ん
[音楽]
[笑い]
たくないん
ん
オーストリアバスケ
んラスボスをはがすとかニュース亮くんない
さあ入らず類ちょっと笑ってくれました
ちょっと今回なんと xperia の3 d クリエイターで作った僕のフィギュア
[音楽]
細いやではしかソフトバッカーの公式ツイッターの方を確認してみてください
いやまず普通にあるんですけどねパソコンの3 d プリンターですね他の楽しみ方も
いっぱいあるみたいです
米 ar エフェクト回声がでですねあで遊ぶこともできますすぐちゃんとついてくる
すぐ本当につけヌルミタネって遊び方ができます sbi xz バーン
いろんなと
結び方があると思うんですけども今回の僕のテーマはこちら
3クリエイターでしたなかなか3 d フィギュアってこう一般の人が手が出せない
ようなイメージがあったんですけれども
今回の xperia xz 1ですごい3 d ということが身近に感じることが
できました
結構ビビリましたというわけで今回はこのあ時代の最先端
がっついたパタヤで今回はこの
第が最西端 x プレイヤー xz バンドのタイアップでした
穴メディア気になってその君ぜひ動画概要欄からチェックしてみてください
じゃん
お父様あっ
[音楽]
me
あっはぁ